that's the whole point of having core
values is that this is the way that you
see the world to take oh I'm feeling
negative I need to shift to a positive
mentality it makes you stronger it makes
you more committed you know it's
building your muscles what's that
believe in Asianet seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I see a lot of people who
are living their life according to
others I see a lot of people who are
getting down by the haters who are
listening to the judgments of other
people and so the point of this video is
to share with you seven ways to make
your own path and ignore the haters also
if you want to know my strategies and
the strategies of other successful
entrepreneurs and how to build
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a 30
second to 5 minute video for free
delivered to your inbox to help you
build unstoppable confidence the link is
in the description below surround
yourself with greatness if you want to
be more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it
[Music]
so way number one is to find your one
word this this starts at one word for me
your one word is your most important
core value when you know what you're
staying for you know what you stand
against you don't allow other people to
infect you and it's for me the
foundation of starting your own path if
you are starting your own path then you
don't start with values I don't know how
your you're building on quicksand
there's no foundation the first level
the first level whether you use your one
word or a different path the first level
is values at a human being basic level
the foundation layer is values and a lot
of people have a sense of their values
you know what is right and what is wrong
but until you can clearly articulate it
and not just like put it up on the wall
like corporations do here are 13 core
values but nobody ever knows them like
no CEO can recite the 13 core values of
their company off by heart and if you
can't even recite them off by heart
there's no there's no way you're living
those things and that's the whole point
of having core values is that this is
the way that you see the world this is
the lens to which you're operating is
how you live and so the base layer has
to be core values whether you're using
your one word or a different technique I
think is the most important way to start
up creating your own path then one of
the people come in and challenge you and
say well you shouldn't be doing this you
shouldn't be doing that often is just a
misalignment of core values you're right
for building it your way ultimately that
doesn't jive with my core value so look
at my channel for example I want to hit
10 million subscribers that might be my
next my next milestone for this channel
or maybe 2 million here at one point for
whatever right now so 2 and then 10
right 2 5 10 there's a lot of ways I
could do it right if I start making
videos on here are the 10 stupidest
things that this person said or here are
the 10 biggest entrepreneur fights of
all time it would start getting a lot of
attention a lot of traction a lot of
views the negativity Reach is much
bigger than a positivity reach because
people hate their lives and they want an
escape and looking at somebody else's
crap your life is better than looking at
their own crappy life they feel better
about themselves because they're
watching somebody else's crap your life
is why we love watching fights and
attacks on each other my channel could
grow much faster
but it doesn't jive with my core value
of belief everything I put out even if
we're covering somebody who sometimes
spews hate if he or she's coming to my
channel it's gonna be positive
everybody's fuse hate still spews a
little bit of positivity now I'm gonna
find those nuggets of positivity of
believe and put it out and that hurts me
compared to what I could be doing but
because I have such a rock-solid
foundation if it's anti believe I'm not
doing it then that person's opinion
bounces off like I get it I love you
thank you so much for the feedback but
I'm not doing it because it's against my
core value that is the foundation your
one word core value is the most
important thing we number two is
understand the work that you love so
next is thinking about what are all the
moments that have made you come alive
you felt the happiest you loved the most
and what was in the work that you
actually love to do in the work of
serving others which you're gonna love
serving you love helping I think humans
are built to serve you're gonna love
helping other people doesn't mean that
every task we did to help people is what
you want to do so example I love helping
entrepreneurs it fuels me it makes me
feel amazing knowing that you guys are
watching this video getting some value
from it it makes my life I love it a
couple summers ago I also offered the
help my my parents in law do their
backyard
Nina's dad works a lot he's always have
time to mow the back lawn and it was
causing him stress and so we decided to
eliminate the back lawn and put rocks
down and I did a lot of that work with
Nina a lot of manual work stuff that I
hate doing I would never do that I never
want to be in the landscaping business I
was for half a summer I never want to do
it again even though the result was
positive in that I helped my
father-in-law now his life is easier and
I still do a lot of things that I don't
like to serve people especially that my
closest friends but it doesn't mean that
I want to be in the landscaping business
and so if you make a list of all the
activities that you've done that you've
loved that have that have helped people
you love the result and then look at
what was the action that you did and
just circle the ones that you actually
like doing that's where you'll
ultimately win when you love the result
of helping people and you love the
process of helping people that's the
most important thing where you love the
process I love helping entrepreneurs but
I love the process of helping
entrepreneurs and so that's the work
that I'm supposed to do that's how I
find my own path and the people say
you shouldn't like entrepreneurs you
shouldn't help them you should spend
more time here it's an easy decision
again because I just love doing that
work and so for you doing that same
exercise finding how you tell people all
the examples write down 20 examples of
how you've helped people in the past and
then what was the work that you did to
help them and how much did you enjoy the
process of it that's what you want a
photocopy that's what you want to bring
into making the business making a career
doing that every day way number three to
create your own path is create
environmental triggers so one of things
I love doing is once you figured out
what you're one where it is designing an
environment around you that supports you
feeling that on a regular basis here's a
challenge you wake up every day you may
not always be motivated and excited to
go to work and do the thing but if you
create an environment a physical
environment like what's on your walls
what's on your desktop background what's
the cell phone background on your on
your cell phone right all of that is
there all environmental triggers that
make you feel a certain way so in my
home office where a lot of my videos are
shot you'll see these five giant
portraits on the wall there's Howard
Schultz as Steve Jobs as my parents as
Kanye's AP Giannini all those people
mean something to me for different
reasons and when I walk in there they're
all looking at me and it sets up a
trigger for myself and what's so great
about having environmental triggers
around your one word they all make me
feel believe in different ways so I
didn't have you know back to rule number
one you understand what your one word is
you know what the kind of trigger you
want to build now we're creating the
environmental triggers the beauty of it
is to shift your mindset there's two
ways to do it
one is by actually focusing on it say oh
I'm clearly negative I need to shift to
a positive mentality and you can do it
the trouble is you don't always catch it
a lot of is subconscious so you may only
catch it 20% of the time you might just
be negative and not catch yourself being
negative what's so great about an
environment is that it automatically
triggers you you set it up once I set up
my office once I set up these triggers
once and then every day I walk in and it
triggers me again even if I'm feeling
negative and I never caught it I'm
feeling better because I had the
environmental trigger in there so when
you know what your one word is for me
it's believed design your physical
environment from the walls the floors
what's on your desk what's on your
desktop background your cell phone
background that triggers you to feel
that whatever it is whether it's the
word whether
somebody's face whether it's a quote
whether it's music like whatever the
thing is that gets you feeling it put
that into your environment so it
automatically happens for you every day
[Music]
way number four is establish a powerful
routine this is another super important
thing I talk about a lot in my videos
most people wake up like an accident
most people spend their day they wake up
they'll they're tired they hit the
snooze button you've just told yourself
that it's okay not to hit your goal when
you hit the snooze button and they look
at your cell phone and you start
reacting to other people's emergencies
right that's it your day is over like
you've lost the first 10 to 15 minutes
have to be designed for you and if you
need longer then make it longer but you
need to own the start of your day you
have to do the thing that makes you feel
excited bold powerful courageous
confident and ready to start your day
whatever that is for you and so this is
almost like the environment as well
where you don't have to catch yourself
feeling negative and then go off and do
the thing you automatically do it every
single day so if you understand what
gets you triggered to feel positive
optimistic courageous bold and then do
that thing then you will feel that way
every day so for me it's it's consuming
something I like consuming a quote or a
thought or you know reading the passage
from the top 10 rows of success and then
I have to share reading alone consuming
alone isn't enough I have to create and
in sharing usually make a quick
15-second Instagram black-and-white kind
of rant video and sharing that I'm ready
to go I need to consume and I need to
create that entire process takes me
three four minutes and then boom I'm
writing set for the day whether yours
takes 5 minutes or 10 minutes or 30
minutes and you need to workout and
meditate and it's 44 like whatever the
thing is however long it takes you as
long it's not taking you like 6 hours of
the morning routine
now it's not morning anymore if you did
the thing every morning that made you
feel bold and unstoppable you did that
every morning for the next year your
life will look unrecognizable from where
you are today you just are not studying
your day with that intention every
single morning do it create your plan so
tomorrow morning you wake up with
intention feeling bold confident and
unstoppable
[Music]
way number five is have empathy for your
haters this might be your parents it
might be people on social media this
might be your friends people in your
industry people in your community if
you're off doing your thing you want to
try to do some bold courageous thing
you're gonna have a lot of people who
don't like that you're gonna have the
people who like the status quo who don't
like anybody changing and doing
something different so they're gonna
hate on you you're gonna have the people
who are jealous of you who hate their
life and they see you trying to escape
and do something different and because
they're too afraid to do it themselves
they have to pull everybody back down to
where they are you're gonna have the
people who actually love you like your
parents and some of your friends who
just see success through a different
lens they see success as going and
getting the job and and getting married
early and having 14 kids and like that
success but you see success is something
else and so they'll hate on your thing
you have lots of people who will hate on
your ideas and hopefully a few people
who actually build you up and support
you have empathy for your haters they're
coming from a different place a lot of
them have a really bad life out for a
lot of them hating on you is the
highlight of their life for a lot of
people come into YouTube video and
leaving negativity is the highlight of
their life for the people who you don't
know imagine how bad a life they must
have if that's the highlight like how
much do they have to hate what they're
doing that that is the highlight other
day and for the people that you do know
look at their life like do you want that
life the people who are who are spewing
hate at you look at what they're doing
look at how happy they are do you want
that life and so just having a little
bit of empathy and understanding of
where this verse is coming from if you
had that person's life you might be
really angry and bitter and negative -
and what I find is it doesn't mean that
it's okay for them to spew that out it
just reduces this thing for the words
that if somebody's hitting you it
doesn't it doesn't drive into your heart
it just kind of bounces off so I think
empathy is a path for your haters it
doesn't mean you have to go hug them and
love them and hang around them more and
try to inject positivity into them just
have an empathy for them feeling sorry
for them to be honest so that the words
that they spread out don't hit you hard
in the face
[Music]
we're number six to make your own path
is to take daily action every single day
you want to be taking action when you
are taking acting or building momentum
and what I love doing is trying to build
half an hour to an hour every single day
on on one of your most important
projects like I say half an hour to an
hour because you might be having a full
time job you may have other
responsibilities that's okay right if
you're already full-time in your
business you want to be sending more
than half an hour to an hour a day on it
but you want to build momentum when you
don't have momentum when you lose
momentum when you spend like 12 hours on
one day working on something and then
don't touch it again for another three
weeks you just suck the air out of the
the progress you suck the air of the
balloon there's nothing left and you got
to you got to do so much work to
rekindle that fire again where if you
every day add a little bit more add a
little bit more a little bit more you'll
allow that momentum to build up you will
feel great about yourself you will look
back and see all these little steps that
look so tiny and significant looking
back was actually we took a big step
like we got a lot done this month even
though every day may felt like just
super small steps and so building
momentum allows you to feel more
confident allows you to see progress
allows you to find your path and when
somebody's hating on you it's a lot
easier to take because when you're
already feeling bad about yourself
for not making progress for not doing
the work for not doing anything for the
past week and then somebody comes and
rags on you it's a lot harder to eat it
it's a lot harder to to not not digest
it it's a lot harder to not take it
personally but if you're making momentum
every day and you're feeling good about
what you're doing like yeah we had a
good month you know it's coming it's not
where I want to be but I'm making
progress every single day spit by bit
and somebody comes and hates on you it's
easier to take it it's easier to have
the empathy for them because you feel
good about yourself so take action 30
minutes to an hour every single day
[Music]
I weigh number seven to make your own
path and ignore the haters is to embrace
the pain embrace the struggle I like
saying it's the best
whenever something negative happens
whenever there's a frustration in the
pain it's the best I'm a big believer
that your purpose comes from your pain
and that this pain that you're going
through the struggle that you're going
through actually makes you stronger it
makes you stronger
and makes you more committed you know
it's building your muscles and it allows
you to help people who are coming after
you the reason why I can help
entrepreneurs so much and I'm so
passionate about it because of the
amount of suffering that I went through
to build my own business my first
company feeling like a total failure
feeling totally rejected and at the time
I wasn't saying it's the best I'd also
didn't have the awareness but even today
making these videos I tried a whole new
format for my in stressor series it took
me way longer way longer than normal to
make like three times as long to make
these videos even though the end results
is probably seeing same length of a
video just me making it took so much
longer and I was frustrated myself when
I was I wanted to do better but in in
recording I'm also thinking this the
past like this Stroger here this is real
this is the best I love this this this
pain I'm breaking my muscles to make
them stronger so anytime you're
suffering every time you deal with
negativity anytime you're dealing with
hatred anytime you're dealing with with
any kind of pain it makes you stronger
to be able to handle it know you can
handle it know you can get through it
know you have the drive the abilities
the smarts to get through it and in
doing so will make you strong your aim
as you climb up to that next step on the
staircase you can then reach down and
bring people up with you because you've
been through it and if you haven't been
through it if you quit if you give up
then you won't be able to help other
people then when your kids say I want to
do this thing but I'm too scared I'm
gonna quit they're not gonna listen to
you when you tell them to go off and do
it because they say you didn't do it
you had your shot you didn't do it why
am I gonna listen to you you got to be
the first you'll be the first in line
you climb a step and you pull people up
to you so they're my seven tips on how
to embrace your own path and ignore the
haters I would love to know from you
guys which one resonated the most with
you is there an 8 9 10 you want to add
to the list leave it in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon
terrific world domination honey Empire
right I'm grateful I understand why I'm
here I think because I am so open I
wanted to think and see it's a bloody
brief life all of you have the potential
for enormous success if you want to know
what Gary Vee DJ Khalid Oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video